the stories that I hear from people that
were alive during Apollo something
happened with them when they watched
people walk down the moon it was this
understanding that anything's possible
those people ended up going on thinking
that for sure people are going to go to
Mars and by the time the year 2000 comes
around were sending people to Alpha
Centauri and it didn't happen there's
like one fundamental reason why that
future didn't happen right after Apollo
it's that everything we've ever put into
space man-made has come from the surface
of our planet what if you didn't have to
watch what if everything in space one
day was made in space the moment you can
start to manufacture things there you
completely change the game
[Music]
this is your guys first time like on the
base right now this area it's a little
weird right like a little apocalyptic
almost when most of us think of the new
space race we think of the shipbuilders
the Elon Musk's and Jeff Bezos and
Richard Branson's those renegade
billionaires who poured their fortunes
into opening up space we don't usually
think of a couple of 30 year olds who
have built one of the world's most
advanced 3d printers but that's exactly
who's behind the little startup based at
a Silicon Valley called made in space
and this is one of their co-founders
Jason Dunn I went to college because I
wanted to be called a rocket scientist I
started to work as an intern at NASA and
for that summer spatial discoveries in
the high bay getting maintenanced and
readied for its next flight and I was
like falling in love with it and then
that summer Charlie Bolden the
administrator came to Kennedy Space
Center and he talked to all the staff of
the Space Center how very soon the space
shows were going to be retired and Here
I am as an intern who's thinking that
I'm gonna go work on the space shuttle
that I just learned all about and that
it's gone I had to start searching for
you know where do I provide my impact
where do I keep the course of humans
living in space on track we were asking
that question why aren't people living
on the moon right now why don't we have
a base on Mars while we could have gone
and looked at all the different ways to
make a rocket better we said you know
what if instead of making better rockets
we looked at a way to not need rockets
to state the obvious going to space is
really expensive right now it costs
around $10,000 per pound to launch
payload into outer space there currently
are a treasure trove worth of spare
parts on the International Space Station
they have backups and then backups for
backups lots of weight lots of space
over a billion dollars worth of parts
most of which will never be used they're
there just in case you can't do that
going to Mars it's not cost-effective
you can't afford that
and here's where we come to the
breakthrough idea what if we could make
all those spare parts and tools in outer
space enter the 3d printer so this is
where the magic happens we're doing a
cribs episode earlier so this is we call
this the bullpen this is a where pretty
much most the people like engineers I'll
work this is our latest album cover iron
made in space a lot of 3d printed stuff
if you look around this is Dylan and
this is Dylan I actually have one at
home that didn't finish printing the
heads like half cut off it's kind of
creepy joking aside it's one thing to
talk about making a 3d printer for use
in space but to build it that's another
thing entirely how do you develop a 3d
printer for the space station without
even knowing if current 3d printers
could work in space can they work in
weightlessness so what we did is we went
to NASA and we told them the plan and we
said if we could fly some 3d printers on
a zero-gravity airplane and if they can
work they should be in space the first
real breakthrough for the company was
when we actually you know built to build
what we thought was a gravity
independent 3d printing technology and
then we're able to deploy that on on
that parabolic aircraft which has the
somewhat unfortunate name with the Vomit
Comet and and actually experience it
working yeah 2001 was the first
parabolic flights and you know when we
first my first saw the results of our
work I was really I was really happy
because we built something that not only
function but now function in the
environment we wanted to function and a
lot of people always say you know oh I'm
working on this or we've been working on
this since you know 2000 and X we're not
working on it we're just doing it in
2011 they got a printer to work in zero
gravity but that was only step one step
to get a printer on the international
space station
as soon as we figured out how to make a
printer work in zero gravity by doing
these research flights on the airplane
it took us almost exactly three years to
get to the point where we have a printer
ready for the space station launch is a
scary time and here's why I had nothing
to do with that rocket I don't know if
somebody had a bad day at work and
decided not to do their job and you know
threw a wrench somewhere it shouldn't be
that's the only part of the mission that
we didn't have anything to do it
it was so tense leading up to that first
time the printer turned on we had tested
so many times and we knew how well it
would work but we're still tense like
getting it set up getting installed and
then then comes a moment to finally like
turn it on and operate it and it works
that moment marked the first time in the
history of humanity that mankind had
manufactured anything off the face of
planet Earth where we headed right now
we're headed into the conference room we
always keep this on display and it's
this is one of the prototypes of the
printer that's on the space station so
this is a good good example of a tool
that we've built in space and this
actually came from the request of an
astronaut asking for a ratchet and we we
designed this ratchet from literally
from nothing and had it printed in space
five days later
the ability to manufacture objects you
know off face the planet do do
manufacturing in space rather than
having to rely on everything to be
shipped up in a in a predefined shape is
is a fundamental shift in how we would
do things in space and it really enables
us to go you know that much further so
the big question is what's next for
maiden space well in March of 2016 they
sent a new print of the space station
but they've got much much bigger plans
than that they've already started
talking about making printers that could
print using moon or Martian deaths sure
it sounds like science fiction but come
on look with this scrappy gang of thirty
year olds with nothing more than a dream
accomplished in just six short years
when I was in college I interned for
NASA and I did it because I loved space
I loved NASA and I really wanted to to
make a difference there but at the end
of the day I always felt like I was
working to help somebody else achieve
their dream and instead of spending my
time helping somebody else achieve their
dream I could spend my time working to
achieve my own you really need to find
meaning and value out of what you're
doing with your own life
[Music]
[Music]